gay pendant 24 heures ou 48
oui les ouïes de marquer 24 et 48 oui
j'ai eu 48 sur la fessée dont 48 heures
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ben on avait
un chien qu'on a donné moi j'avais
décidé de retrouver mon chien de gens
entraînés deux petits copains au passage
vous avez quel âge et 7,1 et comme
j'avais repéré le trajet avec mes
parents ma j'ai refait deux jours
pendant sept heures mais vous avez vous
mangez comment vous avez en cible
on a bouffé des raisins sur des lignes
des trucs sujet rassir et tout et tout
julien je joue pour soi aujourd'hui on a
pleuré on a fini par revenir en a
raconté nouveaux parents devaient être
mort de thembi piles et surtout les
flics avaient commencé à draguer le drac
et l'isère des deux grands fleuves du
coin et donc comme le racontait une
histoire de personnes qui nous avaient
kidnappé j'ai pris une rouste comme
jamais dans ma vie les nerfs de ma mère
on là je vous dis assez bien de lui nous
en mettre une deuxième hors primes et 10
pendant tout l'été que le gogo question
[Musique]
de secondes
oui mais finissait cependant quoi j'ai
une adolescente sunnan de l'essence
super calme un superbe